[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs toutes vos idées sorties dans le
département je suis ravi de vous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle saison on
commence sans plus tarder avec le
sommaire de ce premier numéro
c'était une résidence des plus grands
personnages de notre histoire le château
de rambouillet a terminé ses travaux
après un mois et demi fermés au public
ouvre ses portes pour les journées du
patrimoine nous irons le redécouvrir la
ferme de gally a profité de l'été pour
planter son nouveau labyrinthe et tout
le mois de septembre ce sont même des
nocturnes qui sont proposés pour les
plus aventuriers bruno gansel
responsable communication de la ferme de
gally sera avec nous pour nous en parler
enfin nous retrouverons mélanie poquet
pour l'acronyme junior il n'y a pas que
les scolaires qui font leur rentrée
cette semaine il ya aussi les
associations ce week end différents
forums pour trouver d'activité qui vous
convient le mieux mais la ligue nous
présentera quelques-unes
même si la météo ne semble pas très
engageante ne vous reste plus que
quelques jours pour profiter des grandes
eaux nocturnes à versailles dernières
représentations les samedis 9 et 16
septembre dans les jardins du château
pour les grandes eaux musicales en
journée il reste encore un peu de temps
vous avez jusqu'au 29 octobre
le 13 septembre nous découvrirons
officiellement l'attribution des jeux
olympiques de 2024 pour lesquels paris a
déposé sa candidature dans les yvelines
c'est un événement très attendu car
nombre de structures sont concernés du
vélodrome au golf national avant
l'annoncé officielle willencourt propose
une exposition pour re découvrir
l'histoire des jo
elle a voyagé depuis nice pour faire
étape à l'hôtel de ville une visite
guidée en compagnie du service des
sports aura lieu mercredi 13 septembre à
12 heures
bénédicte alliés queen adjointe à la
culture nous en dit plus sur son contenu
le service est allé en direction du
musée du sport
qui exceptionnellement à monter cette
cette exposition facile à déplacer qui
est ambulatoire comme on pourrait dire
c'est c'est une exposition un petit peu
pédagogique
voilà donc l'idée c'était vraiment que
les enfants aient un plaisir à voir
quelles sont les valeurs du sport
et en parlant d'exposition pourquoi ne
pas participer à celle des jouets
anciens organisé par voisins le
bretonneux
elle aura lieu en décembre et la ville
recherche actuellement des possesseurs
de jouets datant d'avant les années 50
jusqu'aux années 80 vous pouvez vous
pouvez même envoyer des photos d'avant
1980 de vous en train de jouer toutes
les informations pour participer
s'affiche à l'écran et on part du côté
de la ferme de gally maintenant avec
notre invité dès le 9 septembre vous
êtes attendus à saint cyr l'école pour
découvrir le nouveau labyrinthe planté
cet été bruno gansel responsable
communication de la ferme de gally nous
a rejoint
bonjour bruno gansel bonjour alors vous
équipes ont travaillé d'arrache-pied un
tout le mois de juillet le labyrinthe
était fermé depuis le 10 juillet
justement alors qu'est ce que vous nous
avez préparé et bien on a préparé on a
aménagé le labyrinthe de charmilles avec
les personnages des petites pour luthier
une
bd écrite et produite par pocket
jeunesse et donc au sein de notre
labyrinthe on va retrouver tous les
personnages des p'tites poules à qu'il
arrive plein d' aventure l'idée c'est de
retrouver du coup le chemin il faut les
aider cette poule assassinat vient
l'idée c'est de tout le monde puisse
rentrer dans le labyrinthe est
l'objectif comme dans tout labyrinthe au
bout d'un certain temps c'est l'arrivée
en sortir donc pour ce faire il ya plein
de jeux il ya plein de questions il ya
tout un cheminement à parcourir et ça
fait le régal des petits et d un peu
plus grand alors oui vous l'avez dit
c'est fait le régal des petits c'est
accessible pour tous les âges est ce
qu'il ya un niveau oui non c'est
accessible à tous les atouts des sages
il faut que les enfants puissent bien
sûr marché à partir trois ans on peut se
promener et puis après selon l'âge de
l'enfant on va adhérer plus au jeu et
puis pour les plus petits les les
parents doivent les accompagner et les
faire participer faire réagir les
enfants c'est à dire un qui existe
depuis quelques années déjà qui vous
entretenir régulièrement qu'elle était
le travail justement mener pendant tout
l'été par vos équipes
donc effectivement ce labyrinthe a été
planté ya plusieurs années c'est un
labyrinthe de charme de charmeil qui a
d'ailleurs été agrandi cette année c'est
pour ça qu'il a été fermée une partie de
l'année pour faire des plantations pour
l'agrandir pour les années à venir
donc il ya un gros travail de plantation
en grandir de ce labyrinthe pour les
années qui viennent
et puis après d'aménagement du
labyrinthe avec tout se paie tous ces
personnages des p'tites poules avec tous
les jeux à imaginer toutes les questions
imaginé pour que les enfants se
promènent et passe un bon moment donc on
pourra découvrir toute cette nouvelle
toutes ces nouveautés deux journaux si
comme de nuit parce que pour les
aventuriers vous avez enfin pour les
plus aventuriers en tout cas vous
proposer des nocturnes également
effectivement donc ses labyrinthes vont
être ouverts les 3 samedi soir à venir à
partir de demain et puis les
le samedi suivant on ouvre à 16 et 23 9
16 et 23 septembre
on ouvre à 17 heures et on ferme vers
22h30 dont l'occasion dont on aura
l'occasion de participer de parcourir
ces labyrinthes de nuit avec une lampe
torche qu'on peut amener et puis si à
côté des labyrinthes des grands espaces
de pelouse où on va avoir plein
d'animations il ya un espace qui va
destiné à préparer des barbecues pour
que les gens puissent faire cuire et et
griller la viande qui vont pouvoir
amener ou les légumes
il va y avoir un espace destiné à
recevoir une compagnie théâtre la
compagnie à vals aunis qui vient
régulièrement chez nous à plusieurs
reprises dans l'année et qui va
présenter l'ours et nocturne au
labyrinthe une pièce qui s'appelle de
minotaure
débout pièce de théâtre qui est du
ressort modo trois quarts d'heure et en
plus nous faisons venir une compagnie
musique traditionnelle qui s'appelle
gallo vial et qui anime toute la soirée
avec de la musique traditionnelle avec
de la viole
du viol rompt des tambourins des
tambours des flûtes beaucoup bougé que
traditionnels beaucoup d'animations
aussi autour du labyrinthe n'emballe un
petit peu exactement un espace où les
gens peuvent venir danser participer à
ce moment festif et on va voir un petit
peu plus loin parce que du coup alors le
labyrinthe nocturne la preuve le premier
soir du coup c'est ce samedi 9 septembre
on va parler d'un autre événement alors
là c'est pour les plus tôt pour les
gourmands c'est les 16 et 17 septembre
vous organiser la fête du fromage
alors qu'est-ce qu'on pourra retrouver
exactement 16 septembre durant ces deux
jours au sein du magasin de la ferme de
gally on accueille un bon nombre de nos
producteurs fournisseurs de fromage ou
produit laitier parce qu'il n'ya pas que
du fromage aura des producteur de
yaourts des producteurs de fromages vins
de producteurs de beurre de crème et
puis de fromage alors de deux chefs
ayant un petit peu toutes les régions il
ya bien évidemment des producteurs qui
viennent des yvelines
je pense à la ferme de viltain la
bergerie des trois-ponts auffargis et
puis des producteurs qui viennent un peu
plus loin il ya notamment un producteur
qui viendra du cantal département bien
connu pour ses productions de saint
nectaire de cantal de la gueule et
autres et qui viendra présenter ses
produits et qui fera également l'aligot
ce fameux pas que peut-être un certain
nombre
de gens qui nous regardent ont une
occasion de déguster cet été s'ils sont
passés dans le secteur du cantal de
l'aveyron fait à base de pommes de terre
et de tomme fraîche de cantal donc on va
faire de la ligue au gros plat d'aligot
et les gens pourront également déguster
l'objectif de ces deux journées est
d'arriver à faire se rencontrer les
producteurs qui travaillent à l'année
pour proposer des produits dont ils sont
fiers qu'ils sont goûteux et qui sont
bons et faire rencontrer ces gens là
avec le consommateur final et on pourra
aussi et surtout goûter les spécialités
au café de gally dont un seul en tout
cas merci beaucoup bruno gansel de nous
avoir présenté ses différents événements
alors avis aux aventuriers et au
mouvement
la ferme de gally a pensé à vous pour
cette rentrée et toutes les informations
sont à retrouver sur le site internet
merci beaucoup bruno ganz elle merci à
vous on va parler histoire à présent le
château de rambouillet ouvrira à nouveau
ses portes au public pour les journées
du patrimoine
il avait fermé en 2015 pour des travaux
de rénovation extérieure
nous sommes allés le redécouvrir
[Musique]
c'est ici que les plus grands noms de
l'histoire de france venait se reposer
au coeur de la forêt de rambouillet de
françois 1er à louis saez et marie
antoinette ou encore le général de
gaulle cette résidence a traversé les
siècles depuis le moyen-âge des années
qui commençait à peser sur l'édifice
on avait des fuites et puis certaines
parties d'enduit
s'enlevait l'isolation des salles a été
très mauvaise parce que les menuiseries
date du xviiie siècle pour la plupart
donc on a entamé cette campagne de
restauration en 2015 en restaurant
entièrement le clos et le couvert
c'est à dire de la charpente en
comprenant la toiture les menuiseries et
les façades
tout a été entièrement restauré pendant
deux ans qui ont donc un éviter la
fermeture du château pendant cette
période coût du chantier plus 2,5
millions d'euros
des travaux qui touchent à leur fin
quelques installations à l'intérieur
préparent la réouverture du 15 septembre
le public pourra re découvrir la grande
variété des pièces du château comme ses
boiseries rocaille du xviiie siècles
considérés comme les mieux conservés en
france aujourd'hui où les chiffres de la
comtesse de toulouse où on est chez
napoléon imposé chez le comte de
toulouse
un coup on est dans l'appartement des
chefs d'état étrangers
tu as des appartements d'époques
différentes qui se succèdent
justement ça invite vraiment le visiteur
à faire un voyage à travers le temps un
voyage avec une exposition du 15
septembre au 22 janvier sur la famille
bourbon toulouse penthièvre propriétaire
du château au xviiie siècle pour les
journées du patrimoine de nombreuses
animations seront proposées aux
visiteurs
[Musique]
les vacances sont terminées la rentrée
est passée c'est le bon moment pour
réfléchir aux activités à faire après
l'école
ce week-end les villes organisent leur
traditionnelle fête des associations on
retrouve mélanie qui en a rencontré deux
et qui va vous les présentez bonjour
mélanie contente de vous retrouver idem
camille un déjà première question que
vous avez dû souffler que vous est ce
que vous aimez l'eau alors pour souffrir
passera au mais son jeune âge et oui
peut-être cette idée originale pour vous
puisque à saint quentin en yvelines on
peut pratiquer de la plongée et oui pas
besoin d'avoir un océan où la mer près
de nous la palme plaisir oise propose
plusieurs activités en milieu aquatique
la plongée avec des bouteilles de
l'apnée du tir sur cible c'est ce qu'on
voit à l'image du secourisme et de la
biologie et les activités se font à la
piscine des clis ou pas su vraiment
ouvert à tous les enfants de à partir de
8 ans sous certaines conditions comme
des bilans pour les oreilles voilà il ya
des bilans un peu plus poussée et sinon
ça s'adresse vraiment à tout public
garçon/fille savoir nager pas forcément
dans un premier temps parce que pour
être
dans a plongé pour pratiquer l'activité
on n'a pas forcément besoin de d'être un
excellent nageur mais on doit un peu
habitué avec le milieu aquatique
les cours durent une heure et demie
c'est une fois par mois pendant 45
minutes il y a un peu dommage d'apnée et
descendent des ans dans l'eau ensuite
c'est travail avec l'équipement à noter
il faut que les parents soient présents
lors du court et c'est qu'on la reprenne
le mardi 19 septembre alors une année et
coûte environ 100 euros
et tout le matériel est fourni par
l'association il faut juste avoir bien
sûr son maillot et son bonnet de bain et
pour découvrir à leurs activités le site
internet s'affiche en bas de l'écran et
les membres de l'association seront
présents au forum de plaisir ce samedi
et pour ceux qui voudra faire une autre
activité autrefois une acuité autres que
sportives mais la nive au total à leur
rencontre de magicien oui et plus
précisément de l'association de
prestidigitation et divisionnisme d ivry
qui existe depuis 2001 et la découverte
se fait sur trois ans et coûter
la première année on fait ce qu'on
appelle du close up donc c'est ce qu'on
appelle de la magie de près on est
vraiment à distance de bras si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi
après la deuxième année on fait du close
up et du salon et petit à petit on
recule à et la troisième année on fait
de la scène donc la scène c'est
simplement la femme coupée en deux que
tout le monde connaît ou
comme on irait hd des grandes illusions
par exemple des tables volantes des
limitations
la magie on peut la commencer dès 11 ans
pas plus tôt alors c'est une question de
taille demain complètement parce qu en
fait l'association estime que 11 ans est
une limite pour être un bon magicien il
faut bien connaître son tour il faut
aussi faire deux choses en même temps
faire le tour la routine comme il
l'appelle mais ceux-ci s'occuper eux
occupés par dans le public et lui parler
là aussi l'association fournit le
matériel celui des enfants n'est pas le
même que les adultes on peut le voir à
l'image
merci beaucoup mais l'ami en tout cas
pour toutes ces informations alors
n'oubliez pas les différents forums des
associations a retrouvé à saint quentin
en yvelines tout week-end peut être vous
trouverez celle de vos rêves
merci beaucoup mélanie en tout cas de
nous avoir apporté toutes ces
informations
c'est la forme de ce site 8 loisirs je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivis je
vous retrouve vendredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro
je vous souhaite une belle rentrée est
un excellent week end
[Musique]